bonjour katyal procès est donc renvoyée
à mercredi
et oui sans surprise en le procès est
bien renvoyer là nous sommes devant la
trente deuxième chambre du tribunal
correctionnel là où doit se dérouler le
procès de l'ancien premier ministre mais
ce ne sera pas aujourd'hui en tout cas
en fait les avocats des trois prévenus
avaient demandé sans ce renvoi pour
soutenir la grève des avocats contre la
réforme des retraites est bien ça a été
accordée il ya une première audience
pendant laquelle l'avocat de françois
fillon antonin lévy a dit vouloir
exprimer sa sympathie envers ses
confrères et donc le procès est tout
simplement renvoyée au mercredi 26 à la
même heure donc 13h30 et françois fillon
et marc joulaud était donc juger ici le
seront à partir de mercredi pour
détournement de fonds publics pénélope
fillon est poursuivie pour recel et
complicité les époux fillon seront
également jugés pour complicité et recel
d'abus de biens sociaux
la femme du premier ministre a en effet
touché plus d'un million d'euros
d'argent public
entre 1998 et 2000 13 alors qu elle
était assistante parlementaire un emploi
estimé possiblement fictif d'où l'enjeu
de ce procès et pour ces faits les trois
prévenus encourent jusqu'à dix ans
d'emprisonnement
de lourdes amendes est également une
peine d'inéligibilité et concernant donc
les sommes à rembourser je vous propose
d'écouter m yves claisse qui est
l'avocat de l'assemblée nationale mais
ce n'est pas une première pour
l'assemblée nationale que deux demandes
rire
le remboursement de rémunération qui
serait considérée par la justice
encore une fois son mandat n'a pas de
pouvoir de police c'est l'application
d'une doctrine traditionnelle qui
s'applique
de façon constante donc petit rappel des
faits un deux jours avant le procès le
canard enchaîné avait révélé le 24
janvier 2017 l'emploi possiblement
fictif de pénélope fillon
d'autres révélations s'en était suivie
mais le candidat à la présidentielle
n'avait pas jeté l'épongé il s'était
tout de même présenté malgré la mise en
examen et n'avait obtenu finalement au
premier tour que 20,01 % des voix une
vraie sanction pour la droite qui avait
toujours été au premier toit au deuxième
tour pardon durant la cinquième
république
donc aujourd'hui ce procès était très
attendu les journalistes sont partis ils
étaient plus d'une centaine aujourd'hui
à se presser devant cette salle
d'audience et ce procès est également
très attendue par la droite qui a envie
de tourner la page de la sphère fillon
qui avait sérieusement entaché sa
réputation
merci beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
katia technique en direct du tribunal de
paris